- Today, I'm going to share
what I did for Valentine's day.
(whooshing)
(Latin flare music)
(scooter motor revving)
So, it was recently
Valentine's day and in general
I struggle with Valentine's
day because on the one hand
I'm not a big fan of just
buying into made up holidays.
And I like doing things just because.
I would much rather do
something just because
I feel like it has more meaning
than when you're forced to do something.
And maybe just in general I don't like
being forced to do anything.
Maybe that like is at
the core of everything.
As an entrepreneur,
don't put Evan in a box.
I want do my own thing.
Yeah, maybe that's probably at the core
but on the other hand
I really like the idea
of celebrating love.
And so, every year I try to figure out
something special to do.
And so in past years I've
done cooking a meal for Nina,
getting everything setup for her,
and surprising her at home.
♫ When the moon hits your eye
♫ Like a big pizza pie
♫ That's amore
I've also surprised her at work
and showed up in a tie
that had hearts on it,
and balloons and flowers.
And I've given her presents
like I guess we all do
at different times.
We give different presents.
And I don't know,
this year I felt like I
wanted to do something
a little more meaningful.
I wanted to do something that had
you know I wanted to do something that had
more lasting impact.
I feel like if you just go
out to dinner at a restaurant
it's kind of a lazy way out.
It's kind of the expected thing to do
and maybe yeah it's a great evening.
But, it fades
and I wanted to do something
that had much more impact
that lasted a longer time.
And so I was struggling.
What do I do?
What do I do that has that
deep meaningful impact.
And my solution actually
cost zero dollars.
It cost a ton of time
but didn't cost me any money.
What I ended up doing
was writing her a letter
as to the reasons why I love her.
And I thought back to when we
first started our relationship
where we were just dating,
and kind of worked out way
through up into the present day.
All the different things that
I love about her and why.
And I just wanted her to feel it
as I was writing it I
started getting emotional.
I had to take some breaks
and then come back to it.
And she opened it at work
and she read the first
paragraph and she started
getting emotional,
which is the goal, right?
Like, deep meaningful
impact was the purpose
that I wanted to have.
And so she was reading
it and had to put it away
and come back to it later
so she's not crying at
her desk with co-workers
kind of looking at what's going on.
And it took me as I said a number of hours
to put this thing together.
In all honesty,
it took me more time to do
that then to book a restaurant
or to prepare a meal, or to cleanup,
or to show up with flowers.
You know any of the stuff
that I would have done.
It didn't cost me anything
in terms of dollars
but cost me a lot in terms of time.
Ended up having result that I wanted.
I don't know what I'm
going to do next year.
We'll see how I'm feeling
and go with that vibe there.
But, I wanted to share it with you guys
because I think a lot of times one,
we do things maybe for the wrong reasons.
We do things because we're
forced to do something
or we do things that are at
a very superficial level.
And then two,
we feel like we have to do something
just for somebody else's expectations.
We need to go out and we
need to buy that thing
and that's the thing that's
going to make that person happy.
Right, I need to go out and
buy them this expensive present
for them to be happy.
You may not be able to afford that thing.
And really the results,
the win you get from that present,
that super expensive gift,
doesn't last you know?
Doesn't have a long term impact
and so what really touches peoples' hearts
is that deep expression of gratitude
and especially if it's somebody that
you're in a relationship with.
Why you love them.
I'd encourage you to
try that our yourself.
And you know what?
This is a good challenge Believe Nation,
whether you're married or not,
I want you to find
somebody in your life today
who you just want to
express some thanks to.
And either pick up the
phone and give them a call
or write them a nice letter
or send them an email.
Just something really touching as to why
they've impacted your life and how.
I want you to feel the emotion.
I want you to get choked
up in writing that email
or in making that phone call
to express how deeply this
person has impacted you.
And again, it could be a friend,
it could a parent, it could
be a sibling, it could be,
doesn't have to be your
spouse if you're not married.
I want you to get choked
up in writing that message.
And if you do that
they're probably going
to get choked up, too.
They're probably going
to really appreciate you
for writing that message.
And even if they don't,
worse case scenario,
it's still a gift.
You writing that the
intention is positive.
It's still a gift.
And so I'd love to challenge you today
as we close the weekend to
send somebody a nice message
of how they've impacted you.
And I guarantee you're
going to feel good about it
and hopefully so will they.
That's it.
Hope you guys have a great weekend.
I believe in you.
Continue to believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love.
See you soon.